[Music]
have you lost your job or changed
professions in the last two years you're
not alone welcome to our covid19 special
for many people the coronavirus pandemic
spelled financial disaster in argentina
more people slid into poverty while its
12 richest families raked in billions
also on the show around the world firms
were forced to close including private
bus operators in zimbabwe
and from welfare recipient to ice cream
entrepreneur an inspiring story from
south africa though the country is still
battling new covid variants life here is
slowly returning to normal
a crowded venue live music good vibes
that's what mizun tantizo and his band
have been missing for almost two years
south africa's strict covet 19
restrictions have kept things quiet
during that time it really feels good
for the year to open up even though
things are still weird but i'm happy to
see that everyone is enthusiastic most
importantly everyone is tired of being
tired so we're just happy to be outside
and see if we can make it work i guess
it'll never be normal but we'll
establish a new normal but of course we
have to be vigilant and still take care
of ourselves but i'm feeling positive
and good
a feeling people out and about here in
cape town seem to share most ignore the
rules and don't wear a mask while
indoors this despite rapidly increasing
numbers of infections but even
virologists are not ringing the alarm
bell because about 80 percent of the
population have already developed some
immunity mainly due to previous
infections the background of natural
infection and the increasing coverage of
vaccines has really really been
very helpful it teaches us two things
that the immunity is important
boosting the immunity with vaccines
natural immunity and then vaccines is
very important
we really need to get most people
vaccinated this especially as early data
on the new omicron sub-variants ba4 and
ba5 begins to emerge both strains were
discovered by south african scientists
and data suggests they transfer much
faster than others people that were just
infected with omicron ba1 that was the
original one they can easily get
reinfected with ba-4 and ba-5 so we know
that this previous immunity from
previous infection
it is not very protective from second
infection but we still expect that this
immunity will be protective
against hospitalization and death
as long as hospitals remain relatively
empty virologists say there is no need
for bars to remain empty too that's why
they are not calling for tighter covet
regulations in south africa
south africa was one of the few african
countries to pay social assistance to
people who were unemployed and had no
other source of income during the
pandemic
the amount was small roughly 20 euros a
month which sparked controversy
but it helped many survive and a few to
even start a new business
event photography that's what tandoo
makubu did before the pandemics truck
but after almost all events were
cancelled he had to find new subjects to
photograph he saved about 40 euros from
his covet grants to come up with
creative ice cream designs the pictures
posted on his social media channels went
viral and he decided to open an ice
cream parlor at his mother's house
there is no idea this is a stupid idea
you know we just have to try it out and
and and work hard at it so
it feels crazy and interesting and
it makes me
feel that i can achieve anything that i
want
on good days he now makes more than 1
000 euros up to 200 customers find their
way to his home in the soweto township
and almost everyone here heard about the
place online
this morning smiling
i got it on facebook on social media on
tiktok instagram as well on facebook i
found it on social media and when i
found out about it i was like wow
that's he's awesome he's really cool for
doing such things about with a little
amount of money it's very cool most of
our
marketing i can see all of our marketing
we'll say
80
is social media and 20 percent is word
of mouth yeah so mostly social media i
tell a lot of people that
they should try and utilize
social media simply because it's free
the family house now turns into a
business
we are in the kitchen where we make it
happen
i love spending time here i get to spend
more time with my family and it's the
time where we create
our beautiful products
tandoor now employs his sister a brother
a neighbor and his proud mother
he decided let me take a chance let me
see if this will work
and it did work
here we are today he's in a position to
freedom feed himself and
help out in the family because my kids
weren't doing anything yet i think we
all aware there's no jobs in south
africa they've been to school
but uh they can't get employment anyway
well tandoor is the type that wanted to
go report to a boss he wanted to be his
own boss so this is a blessing
since the business is growing fast
soweto creamery is now looking for a
commercial space to rent much to the
liking of tandoor's mother who wouldn't
mind regaining some of her privacy at
home tandoor already has bigger plans he
wants to add waffles and smoothies to
the portfolio and even start some food
trucks
for some the pandemic created business
opportunities like employees of ugandan
startup rocket health
the telemedicine company offers health
services via phone or internet
connecting patients to doctors and
hospitals
at this call center in uganda doctors
consult with patients virtually
dr davis muzinguzi wants to improve
access to healthcare in uganda in 2015
he founded rocket health
we figured out that we needed to
redesign a solution that really solves a
lot of these problems like long waiting
times
the cost of care the quality of care so
by putting together a rocket health
service that starts with you just being
able to have a voice call or a chat or a
video call with a medical doctor we
thought that you know that cuts out your
travel time immediately you get that
help that you need as soon as you need
it and then also being able to integrate
lab services and pharmacy services also
means that you can save more time by
getting care in the comfort of your home
or your office or at school
many people in uganda don't have access
to regular health care some just live
too far away
pandemic related lockdowns made visits
to a doctor even more difficult
and in-person visits also pose the risk
of infection
one of the first confirmed covet cases
in uganda involved a health care worker
in the months that followed many
front-line health workers were infected
most stayed in their jobs but worried
about their families
doctors working from home can help take
the pressure off overcrowded hospitals
and reduce the risk of coronavirus
exposure for doctors patients and their
contacts
it does give you some form of protection
because you're not
you and your client are not in you're
not sharing the same space so if you can
have people stay where they are and you
have this one other doctor at the uh you
know behind a telephone
able to still provide them with the same
services that they would have got if
they actually went to the hospital i
think it benefits both doctors um both
in the telemedicine world and those that
are actually practicing medicine
traditionally
in june 2021 the number of coveted cases
in uganda rose sharply
that same month rocket health recorded
more than 75 thousand telemedicine
consultations
the company also collects laboratory
samples from their clients
and delivers healthcare products and
medicines directly to clients in kampala
and the surrounding region
clients appreciate that they can even
access health care from work
it's convenient and saves time says
sophia nakiranda
the hospital visits like two to three
hours with rocket health i'm going to
make the call
i'll talk to that doctor
in case there is any love that has to be
done they will send someone take the
test as i continue doing my day-to-day
work
davis muzinguzi says less than 10
percent of cases require an in-person
consult
but when the need arises doctors can
send out an ambulance or ask the
patients to come to the company's clinic
the doctor is pleased that his company
is taking off
but the sudden surge in demand for
remote health services during the
pandemic also posed a challenge
we saw our
number of encounters and patients that
we were serving grow by 500 within a
period of one year so it also put a lot
of stress and strain on us to be able to
keep up
with a demand that people are now having
and what we have seen even as the
pandemic starts to subside is that a lot
of people that had that initial
experience with rocket health have
continued to use telemedicine
but for people like davis muzinguzi and
its rocket health company the ideas
tested during the pandemic presented a
business opportunity and helped expand
access to healthcare in uganda
staying in africa we move on to zimbabwe
at the start of the pandemic the
government here banned the operation of
privately owned omnibuses to help
prevent the spread of covid19
only the state-run company could still
transport passengers
dw correspondent privilege musfanhiri
explains what that's meant for many
commuters
here in zimbabwe's capital harare the
lines of people waiting for a bus are
long it's been like this for more than
two years
for student george chiriceri getting to
university every day isn't easy he has
to get a ticket and a seat and steer
clear of the many pickpockets
it's very difficult to get to work on
time or to school
it's very difficult all of the buses
here are expensive
so we're waiting for transportation we
can afford
but there isn't much of that is really
affordable
i got a ticket
he can't always get to his lectures on
time
at the start of the pandemic the
authorities banned private commuter
omnibuses popularly known as combis to
help contain the spread of covet 19.
tino tenda joe also lives in the area he
used to be an assistant in a carpentry
shop after the pandemic hit the
transportation shortage made him late
for work several times so he was let go
now he spends his days by the roadside
hoping to earn a few dollars playing
card games and billiards
about 100 000 jobs were lost due to the
ban on combies
there's little to fill the days for many
of the young people who are now out of
work
some take drugs tinotender joe says
that's not for him
about 20
were grounded by the government's ban
many may never go back in operation
their owners are struggling as are the
drivers and other workers
used to own four buses he had to sell
three of them leaving him with just one
he can no longer operate the ban on
private omnibuses plunged him into
poverty he used to earn at least 240 u.s
dollars a day with his operation
now he's barely getting by working as a
car mechanic
we have to survive somehow
i started selling spare parts from my
bus
when someone asked to buy a part i just
disassembled it from my bus and sold it
before the pandemic i used to repair
combis for other owners but that's over
now too
but things are looking up in early may
the authorities yielded to public
pressure and announced plans to allow
private combies back on the road so
getting to work on time might soon be a
lot easier again
dw science correspondent derek williams
has been keeping you informed about the
latest covid research
this time a viewer asked what happened
to the delta variant has it been
eliminated by omicron
is delta now gone forever and
what do healthcare authorities and
scientists think mutated variants of
covet 19 have have out-competed and
succeeded one another since the
beginning of the pandemic with
a key metric in the equation being
transmissibility
omicron is a lot more infectious than
delta and earlier variants were and
other epidemiological factors being
equal
viruses that are more transmissible than
their peers
can out-compete them
astonishingly quickly infecting the
vulnerable at at such a rate
that slower variants just don't stand
much of a chance um we've seen it three
times already as as this graphic from
from germany's disease control authority
shows um over time
the original virus was replaced almost
completely by the alpha variant remember
alpha which just a few months later lost
out to delta which has now been replaced
by omicron
genetic sequencing has turned up almost
no delta cases in the country since the
end of march and it's not just in
germany
the cdc and the us also no longer
considers delta a variant of concern um
there's
so little of it circulating that in mid
april it was downgraded to what's called
a variant being monitored because
authorities say delta currently doesn't
pose a significant threat to public
health there but the delta variant has
not disappeared completely everywhere in
fact
there are some voices in the research
community that think a delta descendant
might at some point make a comeback
in a recent study an israeli team
tracking variant genomes and waste water
in the city of bioshiva
they've continued to detect delta in
small amounts and hypothesized that if
it remains at current levels
even if they're very low
then there's a chance that as early as
this summer it could possibly surge
again as immunity wanes in the
population
of course
it's impossible to predict the future
but it does seem pretty unlikely
that delta will at some point really
bounce back and and once again pose the
danger
worldwide that it posed back in in 2021
and if one of delta's descendants does
it will likely be
so different from its ancestor variant
that
it'll deserve a designation all its own
[Music]
now we head to south america
a recent study conducted with support
from the german friedrich ebert
foundation shows that 12 of argentina's
richest families got even richer during
the pandemic
while almost everyone else ended up
poorer
[Music]
dw correspondent alejandro rebosio has
more
[Music]
this suburb of the argentinian capital
buenos aires is home to sociologist
oracio calgogno and his family
it's breakfast time
names of argentina's richest families
make up their morning routine there's
jam by the pagani company sugar from
blakia their cable services come from
nopday and their phone and tv from a
company owned by ruben chennaiowski just
a few of the 12 wealthiest names whose
wealth skyrocketed during the pandemic
it's an increasingly unequal world
wife is happy to have her job as a
librarian back she had lost it in the
pandemic and started studying
it motivated me to keep studying just in
case we'll see if covet
the pandemic has further widened the
existing gulf of inequality between
wealthy business owners and the average
argentinian
hernan lecher is director of the
argentinian center for political economy
he and his team looked into who in
argentina benefited from the pandemic
they found that the biggest profits went
to corporate networks owned by just a
few super-rich families
before the pandemic these rich families
owned 29.9 billion dollars
at the beginning of the pandemic
but in february 2021 it was more than 32
billion dollars and a year later it was
36 billion
his study found that following a brief
slump as the pandemic hit these
companies raised prices and still sold
more
but some here in buenos aires say the
profit growth of big companies should be
kept in perspective cristian reyes is an
analyst with one of the country's main
equity firms
he monitors the share price performance
of corporations
in argentina these share prices are
constantly falling and rising
that's because in april 2018 argentina's
economy saw a dramatic slump some
companies still haven't recovered
these days i can't buy meats with what i
earn from the changas the odd jobs
it's only enough for offal which i cook
for my children
i don't cook the way i used to
everything's got more expensive
meat chicken pasta rice everything
horacio calgado and his family are also
suffering from price increases the
pricey ingredients they see on cooking
shows are rare treats
the costs of food and clothing have
soared since the pandemic so much so
that many middle class argentinians are
also worried
many people worried about falling into
poverty during the pandemic they
wondered how they'd feed their families
if they lost their jobs or what else
they could do to earn money
some came up with new business ideas in
colombia there's a saying nothing sells
better than an empanada felipe abondano
tells us how these savory pastries got
one couples through some hard times
[Music]
the sun isn't up yet in bogota but nelly
coramoto perez is she's already been
busy in the kitchen for two hours
before the pandemic she and her husband
worked in a restaurant in the colombian
capital
but it had to close during lockdown and
they both lost their jobs
the couple only recently emigrated from
venezuela and faced financial ruin
until empanadas saved them
we started during the pandemics
we only had 30 000 pesos left
that's around 7 euros
one night while i was sleeping the idea
came to me
i got up at 3am and told my husband
darling i'm going to sell empanadas this
weekend
now she starts working at 4am every day
her empanada business has become her
biggest source of income
it really helped us get out of our
financial crisis
we can pay our bills and our rent again
that's how it started until things
stabilized
meaning that now i do the selling and my
husband also has a job again
in recent days the rain has made sales
difficult but nelly remains optimistic
she sets up her stand on the street and
before long she has her first customer
the pastry and chicken make these
empanadas rich and quite filling
just like at home that's important
it's important
nelly says her empanada business is one
of the few good things to have come out
of the pandemic
[Music]
and i've made it i've built something up
colombians love their empanadas
during lockdown many missed this popular
street food
so they started buying pre-made frozen
empanadas at the supermarket to heat up
at home
that's been a boon for food producers
like simon ferro
it was a huge challenge for us
we had to increase production and for
that we needed more capital of course
so then we also had to deal with the
financing
we were growing ridiculously fast
especially at discount chains like d1 or
juicedo
the places people shopped at most during
the pandemics
his company bought new machines and
hired more staff
jose attienza found a steady job here
we can make over 50 000 empanadas in
this shift
it depends on the client's order and the
production manager
running three shifts we can produce up
to 120 000 per day
making empanadas seems to be a secure
business model in colombia
whether pre-made or from a street food
stall
empanadas have helped many in colombia
get through the pandemic
and that's all for this show
thanks for watching
please join us again next time and until
then stay safe
[Music]
you